weather is the big story of the day of
course sherry it's gonna be so windy
we're not keeping that a secret at all
today in fact we're telling everybody
tell your neighbors tell everybody you
know to prepare for the winds it's a
quiet start to our monday the winds
isn't that a beautiful sunrise by the
way
it is on the way up a few high clouds
off to the east but really the skies are
pretty clear for the valley now we've
got high winds probably the highest that
we'll have
of the season so far for sure and
dangerous winds too for a lot of areas
and for a lot of reasons out on the road
and just generally around town lots of
50s this morning nellis down to 53 so is
the lakes mountains edge at 50 degrees
52 up at centennial hills low 40s out at
red rock this morning not getting much
wind yet southern highlands you're
bumping around a little bit but all of
us will feel an increase in winds as the
morning goes on mid 40s for mesquite 40
for indian springs and mid 50s for
boulder city and front 59 right now in
laughlin 46 for kingman and 36 for cedar
city we're going to have some really
cold air come in behind the wind but
let's deal with the air quality the the
real alert will be for blowing dust and
other hazards on the roads so we'll look
for that really small pm10 that really
the fine dust particles in the air that
will be a really poor quality for the
afternoon anybody with respiratory
illnesses you're probably going to want
to need to stay indoors as much as you
can if you have bronchitis or asthma any
of those emphysema it's just going to be
a hard day to be outdoors with all the
crud that's going to be in the air from
all the wind it's all coming from this
low pressure system and it's a strong
one dropped out of the gulf of alaska
even the aleutian islands way out there
so it's bringing some cool cool air with
it but ahead of the rain and snow is
going to be a cold front the rain and
snow will pretty much stop by central
nevada lincoln county may get in on a
few showers tonight but southern nevada
all these areas of red and blue that's
just wind that we're going to have to
deal with we're looking at high wind
warnings 11 a.m this morning until 3 a.m
tomorrow morning so all day all night
and into the wee hours of tomorrow
morning gusts 50 to 70 miles an hour
that includes the las vegas valley not
just the mountains blowing dust debris
on the roads lots of other hazards and
hazardous crosswinds for those driving
around it is going to be difficult even
bringing the pets if you can could be
holes at the airport power outages
signage blown down shallow rooted trees
we're going to be dealing i'm afraid
with a lot by the end of today 80
degrees for the high that's up a little
bit from sunday we went from 90s to 70s
over the weekend back to 80 northwest
winds so turn out of the north overnight
with that cold front so we're down to
only 60s for highs tomorrow and then
near 70 on wednesday as the winds calm
down back to low 80s before easter but
there are some breezes coming saturday
to cool us just slightly by easter
sunday still looks pretty nice though
our